what do you want to watch I don't know
dude there's nothing to watch just pick
something anything at this how about
this I heard it was good fine great
great
I really love doing drugs and committing
crime also I don't respect women bro
what you support this no I didn't
know this was in it well you picked the
movie I'm gonna kill some people now
because I don't value human life wow
it's probably like a satire or a
critique of this type of person okay
stop trying to defend it I'm a fan of
weird sex stuff and I'm gonna do some of
that right now dude you're into that no
and why did you force me to watch this I
heard it was a classic I don't know I
think it won some Oscars I guess I'll
see you in hell
wow wow